éliminé r bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation dans la matinale de rtl
france
alors le voyage est loin d'être terminée
a assuré donald trump à ses supporters
il n'a pas confirmé à une éventuelle
candidature pour la primaire de 2022
pour autant est-ce que vous avez vu un
homme déjà en campagne oui tout à fait
je dirais que ce discours était un
discours très complet sur tous les plans
il a commencé par expliquer ce qu'était
la présidence by donne jusqu'à présent
et c'est vrai que c'est une présidence
qui s'annonce cette désastreuse pour un
moment mais parmi tous les détails mais
il y aurait beaucoup en donner il a
ensuite rappelé ce qu'il avait accompli
pendant sa présidence
il a ensuite énoncé ce qu'elle serait
son programme pour les élections
suivantes et il s'est mis clairement en
campagne et je dirais qu'il ne fait
aucun doute ni country pour des gens qui
lui sont opposés comme parler d'emploi
est ramenée ou mitch mcconnell qu'il
sera s'il le décide le candide en 2024
je dirais que le son discours était
souvent assez clair je dirais qu'il est
clairement très nettement laissé
entendre qu'il serait sans doute
candidat en 2024 je pense qu'il aura
toutes les chances de l'emporter à ce
moment car si la présidence et baydan
continue sur la lancée de ce premier
mois qu effectivement été désastreux il
n'y aura aucun doute sur le résultat de
2004 ce même chez nous chez lui de 2022
est peut-être un peu tôt pour en juger
guy millière néanmoins on le voit bien
plus d'un électeur sur deux dans le camp
conservateur
on l'a vu dans les sondages pensent que
c'est le meilleur candidat pour la
primaire également au sein du parti
quel est l'homme
le poids finalement de son parti qui le
soutient encore donald trump selon vous
je dirais qu'il est soutenu massivement
ceux qui sont contre d'honnêtes repos
l'intérieur du parti sont les anciennes
establishment qui essaient de sauver
mais cette antienne étape est avec une
autre républicain et complètement
marginalisé la présente comme je l'avais
dit il ya un instant des gens comme mitt
romney des gens comme mitch mcconnell
sont des gens qui ont essayé de tenir au
discours anti trinquent et on voit
qu'ils sont en train de rentrer dans le
rang
actuellement parce qu'ils entament
parfaitement que le parti républicain
est désormais le parti de donald trump
et s'il donne espérer avoir encore une
carrière politique au sein du parti
républicain
il importe qu'elle change de discours et
qu'il se range du côté de donald trump a
d'ailleurs donald trump a été très clair
il a dit que tous ceux qui seraient sur
des positions différentes tout ce que
l'on appelle aux états unis lewin ou
même avec un de seine-et-marne et ce
sont des gens qui n'ont aucun avenir
politique au sein du parti républicain
alors en ce qui concerne les positions
différentes justement pas de changement
de discours depuis plus d'un mois donc
après son départ de la maison blanche
notamment sur l'élection truquée cette
position à ce qu'elle est encore très
soutenue aux états unis plus précisément
au sein des républicains les soutenu non
seulement par des républicains les
républicains sont une grande majorité
que de 75 % à penser que l'élection
était totalement biaisé mais il ya 17 à
18% selon les sondages de démocrates
puis quand c'est la même chose et vous
avez un article dans le magazine time il
est à peu près un mois
signé par un bond des banques et par
ailleurs biographe de nancy pelosi qui
dit explicitement que l'élection était
biaisé d'une multitude de façons mais il
explique en fin d'article que c'était
pour sauver la démocratie donc biaisé
avec la démocratie pour sauver la
démocratie c'est une étrange pratique et
donald trump a dit ne veux plus jamais
si jean-luc mission produisent si nous
on sait que l'ongle est encore dans une
démocratie
question des pratiques dignes d'une
république bananière on la vit
effectivement les néo démocrates qui
n'ont pas réussi à mettre en oeuvre la
seconde tentative d' impeachment contre
donald trump qu'est ce qui pourrait le
rendre inéligible on s'imagine qu'il ne
vont pas s'arrêter là
rien ne pourra nous rendre visible cette
deuxième tentative d' impeachment a été
comme l'ont montré de grands juristes
américains tels que alan dershowitz par
exemple était une tentative d'
impeachment qui n'avait aucun fondement
et puis violée très profondément la
constitution outre le fait qu'elle est
étudiée est ce que parce que prétendre
destituer un président qui n'est plus
président c'est quelque chose qui ne
s'est jamais vu dans l'histoire des
états unis
cette seconde procédure n'est pas relevé
de l'imposture et je dirais que beaucoup
de démocrates à l'ancienne si je puis
dire comme alan dershowitz paiement qui
se détournent démocrates ont considéré
que c'était une pratique très très
dangereux car violé la constitution à
ceux d'autres et c'est quelque chose qui
est du jamais vu aux états unis il y
avait aussi cette question de la
création d'un nouveau parti par donald
trump ce n'est pas le cas il l'a assuré
ce sera l'avenir du parti républicain
comment comprendre ce choix de l'ancien
président des états unis je dirais que
les états unis sont un pays où le
scrutin est un scrutin à un tour
donc nos camps qui se divise est un coq
est condamné à perdre et cela une halte
rappelé le sait parfaitement
tous les gens qui connaissent la
politique américaine le savent aussi
et donc je pense qu'il n'a jamais été
question dans la tête de qui que ce soit
de sérieux de créer un autre parti
politique
de toute façon de partir et puis décale
comme je les dis c'est le parti de
donald trump
si donald reine décide de se présenter
en 2024 je pense que personne d'autre ne
pouvoir oser envisager de se présenter
et c'est tout à fait clair en tout cas
le système en un tour c'est que tout
quand puis se divise est un tank est
condamné à perdre
et donc le parti républicain ne se
déplacera pas c'est rare de voir un
ancien président reprendre le devant de
la scène médiatique
un mois et demi seulement après avoir
quitté la maison blanche
c'est une première est ce qu'ils avaient
avant de revenir si vite donald trump
oui tout à fait il a raison je dirais
qu'il a d'autant plus raison que m'a
beaucoup d'américains se disent comme la
vie l'insee g au sénateur important des
parcs et l'américain qu'il n'y a
personne à la maison blanche qu'il faut
voir qu'actuellement
john dryden ne fait aucune rencontre
publique
il en a fait l'une seul d'agde man an au
texas
il a parlé pendant 3 minutes et son
discours était désastreuse on essaie de
cacher le fait que donald est toujours
très populaire on essaie de cacher aussi
de quelques jobs hayden est quelqu'un de
très diminuée actuellement c'est
quelqu'un qui n'est pas en mesure de
pleinement assuré la présidence et
d'ailleurs vous avez des démocrates vous
allez 30 démocrates du congrès et ont
récemment déposé une motion demandant
que le bouton nucléaire les codes
nucléaires ne soient pas simplement
entre les mains de cobit et je dirais
que sur la correspondance d'inquiétude
je serais très étonné si pur balden fini
l'année à la présidence est encore plus
étonné s'il fait un mandat de quatre ans
mercy 10000 fière d'avoir répondu à nos
questions depuis las vegas je le
rappelle vous êtes chercheur aux
guetteurs au bate stone institute